[Applause]
looking at the process of data analysis
more abstractly Thank You Sen joy and
thanks to all the organizers for
inviting me and doing all the organizing
so I'll be doing talking about
understanding of generalization in
adaptive data analysis and let me start
with a brief overview of this talk so
first of all I will describe the problem
of adaptive data analysis I'll give you
some motivation definitions and basic
techniques and this part of the talk
will be based on two joint works both
with sentient work more it's hard bony
potassium I write gold and Aaron Roth
and many of you probably have seen some
version of this talk but they're
probably enough of those who haven't so
in the next part of the talk I'll
describe some new result that overcome
some of the limitations of these earlier
results and those are joined with Thomas
Paine Cal and finally I'll talk a bit
about oh okay open problems that we're
mostly focus on understanding of
generalization in the context of
capacity convex optimization so let's
start with motivation so we'll be
looking at the standard statistical
setting of learning from data in which
we have some learning problem that is
described by some unknown distribution T
over some domain X and our input is some
data set which consists of n points draw
an ID from that distribution we run our
favorite analysis on this data we obtain
some model and then the question is how
well does this model work on this for
this learning problem which is usually
formulated as the question about the
expected loss of the model on a point
drawn randomly from this of known
distribution P so of course we don't
know there's a known distribution so we
cannot measure this loss directly so we
need to use some type of
statistical inference to say something
about it and usually in machine learning
theory it looks something like this we
start with the algorithms we would like
to understand we assume that it's run on
iid samples and under this assumption we
use our favorite tools such as various
notions of model complexity or stability
and so on and out of this and the
theoretical analysis will obtain
sometimes of generalization guarantees
for this for the result of this
algorithm often some type of bound on
the generalization error of this model
so in in practice learning algorithms
are not used in isolation they can Alice
usually consist of multiple steps and
steps often depend on the previous step
which around on the same data so the the
analysis often looks something like this
the nated analyst will pick some
analysis say a to obtain some result of
running this analysis on the data and
having observed that analysis it might
use these results in the next analysis
which is run on the same data thing
another result and so on and so forth
and there and there might be even more
than a single analyst using the same
data set so some examples of the
procedures that often result in this
kind of reuse are exploratory data
analysis feature selection model
stacking hyper parameter tuning and also
sharing data sets between different
analysts so as you can see the starting
from the second analysis the analysis
that we perform ends up being dependent
on the data so the basic assumptions of
our of the sort of theoretical
guarantees that are based on based on
the data point being drawn iid no longer
holds so it is natural to ask whether we
can still prove something meaningful
about this whole entire procedure even
though our assumptions of our analysis
no longer hope so also note that if we
had an unlimited amount of data we could
just do this simple sort of conservative
data splitting split our data set into
in this case keh keh
different chunks and run each of the
analysis on a separate fresh set of data
and in this way we would avoid all the
problems which are caused by
dependencies but of course in practice
data they they never unlimited it still
often very expensive so the question is
can we do better than this conservative
approach so this is not a new issue if
you open any statistic textbook you'll
find some version of of this classical
claim that you should never test
hypotheses which are based on looking at
the data which is a special case of the
problem there where we're looking at
however with the exception of some
relatively limited cases there are no
good solution to this problem there are
no well aside from this conservative
splitting of the data which is very
expensive and as a result this issue is
often ignored often sort of causing
various spurious conclusions based on
data and they say issues serious enough
that it has been referred for example as
a quiet scandal of statistic by Leo a
famous physician Leo Bremen back in 1992
so back in 1992 machine learning
practice was still a relatively young
area which did not rely on any sort of
formal guarantees and instead the basic
setting looks something like this the
data set would be split into training
and testing the training part was used
to run the learning algorithm and then
the testing set was used just to measure
the expected loss of the model and we
obviously understand that if this test
that is used only once on then the test
error that will obtain will be a close
approximation of the true laws that
we're trying to understand actually the
problem is that this test set was never
used only once a lot of trial and error
was based on the same day data set and
parameter tuning was done quite a bit of
it was done understood that's that often
leading to quite a bit of overfitting to
the test set so since then the sort of
the area has grown up quite a bit and we
serve all these risks to overfitting to
the testing set are much better
recognized so to mitigate them these
days usually the data set is that in
three ways training validation and
testing so training set is used it
before to run the learning algorithm
then the validation set is used to do
some sort of parameter tuning and the
selection of the algorithm and finally
we still use the testing set to just
evaluate there and this sort of setup
mitigates a lot of the problems with
overfitting to the test set but it is
still sort of unsatisfying in for
example it doesn't quite solve all the
problem or caused by sort of this
adaptive reuse of data we might end up
overfitting too
when one does a lot of tuning and these
days we run relatively sophisticated
tuning algorithms and overfitting to the
validation set and optimising towards
the model which is suboptimal as a
result and also the problems which are
solved in this case are solved with
adaptivity by the same conservative data
splitting which is might be too
expensive
in some applications so it might not be
the best approach so let's see how will
formally address more formally address
this problem so as I mentioned our goal
is to find a way to mitigate the sort of
these dependencies that results from the
using the same data set in this adaptive
setting therefore the goal will be that
of our goal will be to design algorithms
which will take the data set as the
input and will interact with the data
and analysts and provide the data
analyst results to their analysis which
behave close to those that would have
been obtained if you Ram the analyst of
each of the analysis on fresh data so
the Pro from the point of view of this
algorithm
each analysis that it receives is a some
type of query about their unknown data
distribution and the goal is to design
an algorithm that can answer these
queries in
when queries are chosen adaptively
meaning that the next query might depend
on the answers to the previous quiz so
let's start by looking at some
relatively simple type of analysis as an
example and these will be the analysis
of the following simple form each
analysis will ask for the mean of some
function for other data element to say
to a real value to say between 0 & 1 on
the data set so just empirical mean of
some function for example that function
could be the loss of the model and this
would give us the test sort of for
example the test error so it's it is
easy to see that if you run this kind of
analysis on the fresh data then the
value that you will obtain will be
strongly concentrated around the
expectation of this function Phi on a
sample drawn randomly from this unknown
distribution therefore being close to to
running this analysis of fresh data
means being outputting a value which is
close to the expectation of the function
on the pointer of drawn from the
distribution and repel panamá tried the
closes by this accuracy parameter tau
and will ask that this value is close
with some high probability say 1 minus
beta so it turns out that this these
particular guarantees have been studied
under the name of statistical queries
back in 1993 by currents and we now know
that you can sort of it be simple
queries can be used to compute many
things for example metric correlation
moment accuracy loss and in general run
many of the algorithms which are used in
machine learning theory so from our
point of view the sort of the importance
of this relatively simple setting that
it will actually capture many of the
problems that one many of the issues
that one encounters when dealing with
adaptive data analysis so to see those
let's start with a very quick warmup
let's assume that you were given sort of
let's look at the non adaptive setting
where you are given K fixed functions
let's say all with range between 0 1 and
the goal is to estimate the expectation
of all of those functions so to do that
one can just use the empirical mean and
the standard sort of Chernoff bounds
like Union bound imply that the number
of samples that you would need to get an
estimate within tau and confidence one
minus beta is something like log K over
tau squared K over beatle over tau
squared so it grows very mildly with K
now let's look at the adaptive version
of the same problem let's try the same
approach of using just answering using
the empirical mean it's actually
relatively easy to see that if you use
this approach then there are sequences
of queries so that the number of samples
that will be required to answer those
using the empirical mean is at least K
over tau squared and those are not even
some sort of unusual queries basically
the queries that often would arise in
variable selection boosting bagging
stepwise regression and so on and as you
can see this is actually not much better
than the conservative data spitting so
doing the sort of the standard
approaching of using the empirical mean
can in principle be very bad so it is
natural to ask can one do better than
this and that's sort of the main result
of this early work which shows that
there exists an algorithm that can
answer K adaptively chosen query
statistical queries of this type with a
cubic c-style given the number of
samples with which grows as a square
root of k and has this tau over 2.5
which again compared to data splitting
is sort of a quadratic improvement in
the dependence on K but with slightly
worse worse dependence on accuracy
slightly later a bunch of people
Basilian ISM Smith Stein customer and
woman have found a sort of a more clever
way to analyze the same algorithm and
show that it actually achieves the the
correct dependence on the accuracy tau
tau squared they also show the
the same algorithm can be generalized to
two so-called low sensitivity analysis
or queries and most activity analysis
are all those analysis that that are
real valued and different between the
value of the analysis on to and JSON
data set is at most one over N so you
can see that that's sort of the
statistical query this Amin is a low
sensitivity query and also these low
sensitivity queries there their value on
fresh data is also highly concentrated
around the mean so this algorithm will
estimate the mean out of the big picture
let's make the expectation of running
the analysis on fresh data so where do
all these algorithm come from so they
rely on the technique developed and
differential privacy which I guess at
this point does not need much
introduction but let me very briefly
remind you what it is it's a condition
for randomized algorithm which takes it
as an input a data set it's a condition
on its output distribution which offly
says that if you look at output
distributions on any two adjacent data
sets these distributions will be closed
and how close they will be
multiplicatively closed on most of the
almost everywhere and possibly up to
some possibly small Delta where they are
not and more formally it has two
parameters epsilon and Delta Epsilon
measure measures the multiplicative
factor and Delta some additional editor
factor it's not very important for this
talk what it is
so why what does this private you have
to do with the problem that we are
looking at and the reason why it turns
out to be a useful notion in this case
is that first of all it turns out the
differential privacy implies
generalization basically differentially
privacy is a form of stability two
changes of an element of a data set in
fact it was known that it implies some
other notions of stability that have
been cited in learning theory such as
uniform replace one stability in
strongly uniform
and this notion itself is known to imply
generalization in expectation which
roughly means that the expectation of
the generalization error is small and
the main technical result in this early
work is in fact it implies
generalization with high probability and
roughly the same error so the second
property of differential privacy that is
makes it important for this application
is that it composes adaptively and what
this means is that if you have K
algorithms your all difference we
private and you run them all on the same
data become both algorithm will also be
differentially private and in fact that
privacy parameter will roughly scale as
a square root of the number of the times
you compose and it was proved by a while
back by twerk Rock'em and butt huh so
now this taking just these two facts
together what we obtained that any if
you take any algorithm differentially
private algorithm which solves the
problem the answer the queries with the
value which is accurate
empirically then it will also solve this
world will also give us a value which is
correct relative to the distribution and
in addition it will work in this
adaptive setting so well by using now
sort of answering this low sensitivity
queries is kind of the most basic
algorithm in differential privacy and it
can be done by just perturbing the
output values so if you are given some
queries which describes the low
sensitivity analysis you can you can
answer it by adding a bit of noise for
example from a Gaussian or class
distribution and this will give you an
answer with the differential privacy and
as I mentioned that it will imply that
you can answer the queries in the
adaptive setting give us giving the
algorithm that I have described extend
so far
okay so a natural pattern can we go
below these low sensitivity queries
there are many analysis which are not
low sensitivity and most activity just
to recall is the so the sensitivity is
the maximum difference between two
values of the analysis on two adjacent
datasets so first of all this approach
can be applied to more generally to not
flow sensitivity queries
however the error that will achieve will
scale with the sort of worst case
sensitivity specifically if you are
given say n samples this Albert
cumulative error achieve error decibel
scale is Delta x square root n times K
over to the 1/4 where Delta is the worst
case sensitivity over all queries that
are being used and over all adjacent
pairs of data set so this factor K is
the price for adaptivity but even this
this part of the delta x square root n
can be much larger than the error that
you would expect if you had fresh data
and in which case the rough aver that
you'll be expect would be the standard
deviation of running that of running a
on fresh data so in a new work with a
Thomas time K will show that there
exists actual an algorithm that can
achieve this sort of optimal error and
more formally the result is as follows
we exist an algorithm Aranea definitely
chosen sequence of analysis now we'll
think of analysis is using key points
some fixed T or they're all real value
given the number of samples which scales
is again square root K times T so we
have the square root K blow-up will
output values which estimate the
expectation of the expected value of
this analysis within two standard
deviation of standard deviations of
running the analysis on fresh data so
just to compare these guarantees for
statistical queries versus the previous
work so if you had the statistical
queries which again functions over over
of a single domain element so to answer
statistical queries with range say my
be be well assume that it's finite at
least the our algorithm will give will
achieve error which is the standard
deviation of this query divided by
square root n because of using because
we because we have multiple samples and
signs this this price for adaptivity
whereas the value perturbation based
algorithm that we have described will
have the factor B which is the maximum
which is the range instead of the
standard deviation and we know that in
many application range will be much
larger than the standard deviation so
let me tell you a little bit about the
algorithm which you refer to as a stable
median because it's basically a variant
of the median of the classical median
algorithm and it works as follows we
given that data set we split it into
three chunks of each of which is of size
T the input to to each of the analysis
and there are M different chunks of the
size we run the analysis that we would
like to execute on each of those chunks
collect the values and let the set of
values be denoted by by you and we'll
plot them here now we basically use we
run an approximate median algorithm on
this set of values and approximate
Mediate is a median is any value which
is larger than one third or the bottom
one-third of the values in the set and
smaller than the top one-third of the
values and we want to find this median
with differential privacy although now
the differential privacy will be not
will be applied not to the entire data
set s but only to the throat of a small
set of values that we have extracted so
so this is a relatively basic and
natural problem and let's see so let's
see how it can be solved actually its
complexity has been kind of resolved on
the relatively recently in a work of
Boone Newsome stemmer and Vuitton who
show first of all that to solve this
problem with differential privacy you
to assume some sort of discretization of
of this ground set so we need to assume
that there is a finite number of values
key here from which you from which
you'll be selecting the de medium and
they show an algorithm which whose
complexity scales is a two to the earth
log star of the number of values in the
ground set which again for all practical
purposes an extremely small value and
they also show that this dependence on
log star is actually necessary at least
or Omega flock start samples will will
be required so this is a relatively
involved algorithm so instead we'll use
a simpler one which is based on the
again classical algorithm of McSherry
and Tovar in in from differential
privacy and this algorithm will output a
value V from this grid discretized grid
with probability which is just
proportional to in some sense the
distance between the rank of this value
the number of elements which in the set
u which are smaller than this this
element and the medians the M over 2 so
the values which are closer to the
median will be output with very high
probability and this exponential
probability will decay as you go away
from the median so it's for this
algorithm is not hard to show that it
will require a log R divided by epsilon
samples so which still seems rather
wasteful given that we'll have to kind
of sample log R times but actually
because this it's a median algorithm
also combine confidence simplification
so basically get both both high
confidence and stability for the price
of a single log factor so actually
increase in sample code X you will be
more like a constant that may be even
small very small constant so let me
briefly mention how we analyzed it so
the base the sort of the key the key
result is that we use is the
differential privacy approximately
preserves quantiles of a distribution
a bit more formally we show that if
there is some differential private
algorithm which given it this data set
you of size M output the algorithm
output a function size of an element of
the data set and also some real values
then with high probability over sampling
of this data set from some distribution
G and the taking the function Phi and
the value V to be the output of the
algorithm then this probability which is
the true quantile of the value V for
this function Phi is close to the
empirical quantile of again the same
value or for the function of for the
same function apply to the due to an
element of the data set so now from this
theorem what we are saying that if we
have a value which is within one-third
and two-third of empirical empirical
quantile which is the definition of our
approximate median then this value will
be also within 1/4 and 3/4 of the true
quantile for appropriate choice of
parameters and that's also in particular
implies that will be within two standard
deviations of the true mean and in
addition sort of sorts ok so let me show
that this analysis is based on the
reduction to sort of this analysis that
has previously done for statistical
queries that is relatively involved if
you want to obtain high probability
bounds but one nice feature of the
analysis we give here is that if this
Phi is well concentrated then we can
also get much simpler much more
accessible analysis which proves high
probability bounds for this statement ok
so let's that's all that I wanted to say
about the the positive result let me now
describe some of the limitations so
first of all have been shown a while
back by heart and omen and then improved
by striking an omen that basically if
you don't make any assumptions either on
the distribution or the algorithm then
any algorithm for answering Kate does in
silico queries with accuracy Tao will
require the number of
samples with which scales the square
root of K so in some sense our algorithm
is the best one can achieve without any
additional assumptions although one can
do slightly better in low dimensions and
in efficiently so there are some
assumptions for this result so one so
one way around this sort of limitations
is to look at somewhat simpler problem
of verifying the responses to queries
where basically one can again use
algorithm from differential privacy to
show that given a number of samples
which scales as a log K times sort of
square root C one can verify K queries
as long as at most C of them fail the
verification step so and using this
algorithm one can build some some nice
application for example one can do data
splitting only if overfitting happens
one can get a hold out which is reusable
for and still has some probable
guarantees and also one can basically
maintain the public leaderboard in a
competition with some provable guarantee
which was shown by plumbing Hart so
another sort of open problem is really
yeah there is also a factor tau gap yes
that that's sort of a second order an
open problem here and yes so but another
related problem is proving is
understanding the case where basically
we restrict the analyst to not have any
sort of do not depend on the unknown
distribution P that sort of the lower
bound the attacking the lower bound
requires coordination between the
analyst and the unknown distribution P
and the question can would this what is
the sample complexity of this adaptive
data analysis with a without such
coordination specifically one can ask
does there exist the specific
statistical query analyst analyst which
only use these simple statistical
queries
the queries which are produced by this
analyst will require more than all
flawed case samples to answers and
herewith against a some fixed accuracy
for simplicity of 10% and confidence so
there is still no we still don't know
the answer to this relatively simple
question and beyond it is also
interesting to ask this question about
some specific natural analyst or
specific natural learning algorithms
which ask with how many samples will
they need to will we need to answer the
queries and that sort of will allow us
to understand the to understand when
adaptivity
requires more samples to deal with so my
favorite is sort of these natural types
of algorithms is the gradient descent
when it's used for stochastic convex
optimization and let's look a little bit
more this example so first of all what's
the classic convex optimization and
we'll look at some relative very simple
settings in which we have them well our
convex body K will be just the D
dimensional unit Euclidean ball and the
class of functions f over the ball will
be all convex one Lipschitz functions
we'll assume also that are there all
differentiable so in this problem this
of the practicalness optimization we're
given n samples which are all functions
which are all functions drawn a
different unknown distribution p over
all of these functions and our goal is
to minimize the true or expected
objective which is just the point-wise
expectation of a function drawn from
this distribution which will also be a 1
Lipschitz convex function and
specifically would like to optimize it
within some with some epsilon parameter
so and that's roughly how it looks you
get to get up there a bunch of functions
but we need to optimize some functions
which we function with which we haven't
observed so one classical approach is to
you to solve this problem is to use
gradient descent
and sort of maybe not as popular these
days it would you would use the gradient
descent on the empirical objective which
is just the average of the function that
you have observed then it's the standard
gradient descent you will start with
some point doesn't matter which one and
then for some T trations you will take a
gradient step and will project back to
the convex body and because we don't
assume any smoothness you will have to
use some sort of averaging at the end so
one what's the reason I think this
problem is interesting is that we don't
know how many samples we need for this
problem to ensure that the solution that
is outside by this algorithm generalizes
to the underlying distribution that
actually solves the stochastic convex
optimization problem that I have defined
so what we know that we can use sort of
the standard machinery of uniform
convergence where we prove that every
solution its generation error is small
but to achieve sort of uniform
convergence in this setting one needs
it's well known that G over epsilon
sample suffices and turns out that
actually these this number of samples is
necessary so we get proved recently so
there's no hope that that you can
improve this upper bound at the same
time if you use the stochastic gradient
descent for the same problem you will
obtain a solution just which will
generalize using just one over epsilon
squared examples without any dependents
on the dimension G and this is using
this again classical as well this
particular version will be due to
[ __ ] so so let's see why do we sort
of don't why do we not understand this
algorithm why it's hard to understand
let's see this gradient computation and
this is again it's a gradient of the
empirical objective is just the average
of the gradients on the point that we
have obtained and it's easy to see that
if you actually executed each of those
on fresh samples if you can give you the
gradient using fresh samples then the
empirical gradient would be close to the
true gradient up to say 1 over square
root n so for n which is roughly 1 over
epsilon square
that would suffice to get sample
complexity which is just 1 over epsilon
squared they mention independently
however the problem is that sort of once
you make so so in the first step indeed
all the samples are fresh but once you
use the samples to make the step the
iterate the place in which you're you
know the the x2 already depends on the
samples so basically you can no longer
apply this this argument no longer
applies because the point in which
you're trying to estimate the gradient
depends on the on the data points on the
data so we actually don't know how close
the gradient will be to the through
gradient we don't have a good way to
argue about the generalization of this
algorithm so we can also look at this
particular algorithm the point of view
of the of the results that I have
mentioned we can think of this algorithm
as asking so each of estimating each of
those gradients is basically just you
can decompose it into these statistical
queries you can think of it as just
trying to estimate your epsilon
statistical queries and it's easy to see
that the accuracy that would suffice is
roughly epsilon but this there will be
as activity in queries the queries will
be dependent on on the previous answers
and there are 1 over epsilon squared of
adaptive rounds this is sort of again to
make sure that it's the all the
parameters would work so to get the
epsilon error you would need to set T to
1 over epsilon squared this is a
standard parameterization so one could
try to see so how many so this is a
particular specific adaptive algorithm
and it's actually a common example do
you need to answer these adaptive
queries and we don't know just what can
easily observe is if you use sample
splitting conservative bound then you'll
need some like log G over epsilon to the
first sample you would use separate
samples for each of the gradient
gradient and if you use the analysis
that are these sort of the ideas that
I've described before you would get some
upper bound which is Square D over
epsilon to the 3rd
it's an incomparable bound and both of
them are incomparable to
to the uniform convergence bounds and we
again we don't know and those are worse
than the bounds that we know are
necessary for such a stochastic gradient
descent so yeah so that's one of the
open open problems which I very much
like to understand so that's roughly all
that I wanted to say yes sorry do you
hope to give any insight to this issue
that a GDC severe form of regularizer
maybe that's the conjecture in so in
some sense problem here is not about as
GD so ng D we kind of ER is easy to
understand because it doesn't reuse
examples like at least in the sort of
the standard version we analyze and yes
there is ok some way to see it as a
regularizer
both in individual steps and also as the
number of steps but I don't think it's
quite as yeah I think it's not quite
related universities not needed it more
yeah yeah I thought it will not give us
the the answer that we sort of believe
is probably true Medicare yes again I
don't know the answer maybe it will
eventually require the over epsilon
squared samples but we know but I don't
think there is a good reason to believe
that this particular algorithm we don't
have any examples showing that this
algorithm will need that many samples I
think that I would conjecture that uses
the same number of sample just as SGD in
this case anyway so let me go to
conclusions so first of all does in the
first part of the talk I showed it from
the point of view of understanding this
sort of real valued analysis and without
making assumption we sort of understand
this case relatively well we know that
roughly we have to you have to pray pay
this price of square root K if you don't
place any additional assumptions
although there are some some open
problems as I have mentioned once you
add additional assumptions beyond that
one interesting problem is going beyond
the tools of
differential privacy for now all the
best results that we have are based on
on these techniques that have been
developed over years in differential
privacy but it's I mean well it's not
necessarily the best approach for the
problem because again we don't care
about the privacy itself here so there
are some nice works which which try to
do to go beyond this for example people
look at the other notions of stability
in the space of outcomes and also more
holistic view which is basis or max or
mutual information between the data set
and the output of the algorithm on the
same data set so and the other question
which dimension is related is
understanding of generalization beyond
these bounds of uniform convergence
which seems to be closely related to
understanding of of adaptive reuse of
data somehow things become much harder
than this seems to be a very timely
topic these days so finally I haven't
talked much but some of these ideas
these ideas can be used in practice and
that's eventually the goal even the some
of the basic insights have already had
some nice applications but we still
understand very little and we would need
to understand more to apply these things
more successfully so that's it please
let me know if you have any question
thank you
[Applause]